welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Howard Dean an alumnus of the class
of 71 he has returned to Yale as a
senior fellow at the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs to teach a seminar on
the politics of foreign policy many of
us are familiar with mr. Dean from his
run for the presidency in 2004 prior to
that he served as governor of Vermont
for six terms from nineteen ninety one
to two thousand three mr. Dean was
elected as chairman of the Democratic
National Committee in 2005 serving until
2009 as chair he was lead strategist
spokesman and fundraiser for the DNC mr.
Dean is credited with pioneering and
energetic 50-state strategy and the
development of 21st century campaign
tools that helped Democrats make
historic gains in the 2006 and 2008
elections before entering politics he
was a practicing physician mr. Dean
currently works as an independent
consultant focusing on the areas of
health care early childhood development
alternative energy and the expansion of
grassroots politics around the world he
also continues to be active in the
Democratic Party politics today we'll
talk with mr. Dean about foreign policy
in the Ukraine Iraq and Syria welcome
mr. Dean thanks for having me on you are
here at Yale teaching a course about
foreign policies so basically you review
the domestic political concerns or
pressures and how they are affecting
u.s. foreign policy since world war two
are you looking at these countries now I
know it's very early in the semester but
are you looking at Syria
and Iraq and what's going we are we're
starting actually now with Iran and Iraq
and the domestic policy is considerable
the domestic influences on these the
domestic influence for the Iranian
situation goes back to the of course the
famous hostage situation which went on
for over a year with Jimmy Carter when
Jimmy Carter was president then Ronald
Reagan on his inauguration day they were
freed by the ayatollahs and that still
is a very much of a political football
it's very difficult for President Obama
to have any kind of an opening to Iran
without enormous pressure from the right
using this anti-iranian sentiment in the
United States which goes back to those
days but the truth is and the kind of
thing I like to talk about in classes
our difficulties with Iran went back a
great deal longer than that in fact were
of our own making in 1953 we the British
deposed a the only democratically
elected prime minister in the history of
Iraq elected by Parliament i might add
not by the people of Iraq Iran I excuse
me and that had had we not done that
history might have been completely
different so there are lots of very
complicated aspects and one of the
things I really try to stress in dealing
with all of American foreign policy
particularly in the post-war era is that
there are short-term decisions that are
made and they don't always turn out well
in the long term and I'm trying to
encourage as much long-term thinking
about American foreign policy as
possible so that we don't we make we
don't make stupid short-term mistakes
and then find that we're paying a huge
price for them later on isn't it
difficult to take the long view
sometimes depending on what's going on
and what the political pressures are
sure the political pressures always
encouraged people to make that take the
short view and in fact our electoral
system always encourages people to take
the short view because they're always
worried about the next election there
have to be some people with big pictures
either capability of having a big
picture view or like Harry Truman a
willingness to do things against the
political drain I don't now I I grant
you that one of the big sources for the
Truman administration
was makalah's biography of Truman which
is absolutely spectacular and I think he
has a you know a very idealistic view of
Truman but nonetheless Truman was
somebody who made very tough decisions
without regard to the politics
particularly for example in the firing
of General MacArthur and those kinds of
decisions as have stood us very well
Truman despite his fact that he never
went to college was completely in the
dark about most everything that
Roosevelt was doing when Roosevelt died
and he became president turns out to be
a monumental figure in American history
particular post-war history because
under his administration almost every
major institution of the post-war era
was formed not just simply because of
Truman but because of the people around
him and the people and in the
relationship he had with people like
George Marshall and Dean Acheson well
let's look at some of those areas of the
world today the Ukraine for instance you
know what should be the long-term
picture there instead of the short term
well the long-term picture of course is
largely going to be determined by
Vladimir Putin what Putin's clearly
trying to do is destabilize Ukraine in a
way that will allow him to have the kind
of influence that he had when President
Yanukovych was in power who was
basically a corrupt for wanting of a
less diplomatic word fool who was doing
whatever Putin told him to and making
lots of money doing it and the reason
for that was that Putin has some i would
say perhaps delusions of grandeur and
also some of the traditional sort of
paranoia russian foreign policy some of
which is of course well deserved a
well-earned and this vision of this sort
of greater russia that he was somehow
going to go back to the old russian
empire at the height of the soviet
empire at the height of its of its reach
and that's it's not true there are
probably some things we have done that
made it more difficult for us but
largely it's Putin's there the next door
neighbor if Putin wants to disrupt
Ukraine there he's going to be able to
do that successfully and we have to make
him pay a price for it in the long term
I actually think the president's
President Obama's
policy in Ukraine is exactly right this
gradual tightening of sanctions is much
more effective than anything else we
could do okay what about Syria and Iraq
much more complicated Iraq of course was
doomed the day that George Bush sent
troops there and I actually said that 11
years ago almost well I'm not quite to
the day but I predicted 11 years ago
that if we sent troops to iraq for
reasons that turned out not to be true
which i suspected at the time based on
British intelligence that i was looking
at if we went to Iraq we first of all
would strengthen Iran immeasurably and
second of all Iraq would be divided into
three countries Kurdistan Shia Iraq
which would be heavily dependent on Iran
which has happened and I also predicted
that al-qaeda would come in and use
Eastern Iraq or western Iraq as a base
and I was wrong and that one it was Isis
instead of al-qaeda but still a very
dangerous terrorist group so you know
the big the die has been cast and we now
and the president has to live with the
folly of what I think was the which I
used to say this the largest debacle in
American history and the biggest mistake
although you have to say the war of 1812
where we got our capital burned down
might have been greater but this is a
disaster and now we're having to clean
up this horrible mess which actually
can't be cleaned up george w bush
changed the geography and the balance of
power in the Middle East in ways that
are bad for the United States forever
and that can't be undone but there are
some things we can do like what in the
future first of all I think the
president's negotiations with Iran or a
good idea I think they won't succeed but
I think they need to be done why don't
you think they'll succeed because I
think the Iranians are playing for time
the sanctions are very very effective
and what rouhani who is not a moderate
at all is intending to do is to buy time
get the economy back on its feet which
is which is happening to a certain
extent but does not intend and could not
domestic from his own political problems
domestically give in or give up the
potential of having a nuclear
I don't think that's a winnable goal
nonetheless I think talking is better
than a shooting and so I think that the
president has done the right thing in
that area what about the bombings we're
doing do you think we should be doing
that we have to we have no choice I
don't I think the president also right
with that we cannot have boots in the
ground we made that mistake in Vietnam
and paid a terrible price for it we made
the mistake in Iraq and played a
terrible price for it you cannot defend
with American troops on the ground a
country that doesn't want to defend
itself we defended corrupt dictators in
Vietnam on the idea that it was
anti-communist which turned out not to
be true was actually a nationalist
problem we defended Mollett we propped
up Malachy we've propped up Karzai both
of them are corrupt people people who
won't fight for themselves don't deserve
how to have American boots on the ground
it's not too many successful airpower i
think is successful my view of what we
should happen in iraq is that we need to
work with the Kurds who are very
motivated to have their own country we
should recognize Kurdistan at some point
and not now but at some point and we
that needs to be the core of the ground
troops that will fight against Isis and
we should support them vigorously by air
so in terms of the beheadings that Isis
are doing and looking for the bigger
picture and also the political pressures
that are you know there's a lot of
public sentiment that that you know
wants to bomb now with beheadings I mean
what do you think the look the larger
longer picture she's no longer picture
is as long as you don't have American
casualties there'll be support for that
while academics and others on the
progressive end which includes me and I
mean that's usually where i am condemn
the drones I think drones are essential
because I think drones are a substitute
for boots on the ground these people are
terribly dangerous in this notion that
somehow you can repel evil and violence
without using violence yourself it would
be nice if the world were like that and
I really genuinely wish it were but it's
not I heard a stunning report on the BBC
on the way over about a young man from
Kosovo a company
country that I've spent a lot of time in
who was indoctrinated and and
brainwashed by the by Isis and just blew
up 15 or 50 innocent people in the
suicide bombing and then he also there's
another Kosovo kid unemployed you know
seduced by Isis went to Syria and
publicly beheaded a Syrian soldier these
people are dangers they're dangerous to
the world they're dangerous to us and we
have to use whatever means necessary to
get rid of that I mean it strikes me as
it's a very grassroots kind of campaign
that they're running which is very
different from other kinds of military
operations I think I mean how do you
combat something like that someone going
into a crowd and blowing them up how do
you stop that from happening and even
they're not a hundred percent successful
you have to have great intelligence you
do have to have them which is something
i think we're lacking in this country
yes it's getting better but having human
intelligence is very hard and that's
what we're missing we're relying too
much on technology but but we are you
know where are we have fortunately knock
on wood headed off a major attacks on
the homeland of the United States that's
important you also have to do
pre-emptive things and you have to be
very careful because if you become an
authoritarian state yourself then of
course you'd really do create more
potential recruits for Isis or other
terror groups like that there was just a
raid in Kosovo rounding up kids who are
becoming extremists and in this country
that probably wouldn't be allowed you're
probably allowed to think and say
extremists things as long as you don't
actually carry them out in other
countries they have less of a tradition
of the First Amendment traditions and
Fourth Amendment traditions and measures
like that are going to be necessary so
if you were dictating foreign policy
what were some other thing what would be
some of the things that you would put
into effect um well nobody nobody can do
that including the president well would
you try well say I think I actually
think that the President Obama's foreign
policies is very good
you know he's getting the daylights beat
out of him by liberals and conservatives
alike but what he has done is to
articulate the policy that began with
the collapse of the Soviet Union and and
it was never really articulated partly
because President Clinton was very
involved in stopping genocide in Bosnia
and some things like that President Bush
believed in the moulton a unipolar world
which turns out of course not to be
realistic what this president has done
is articulate something that's been
developing since the collapse which is
the notion of a multipolar world where
alliances are the mode of action any
articulating that is West West Point
speech which most people didn't pay any
attention to partly because it wasn't
that well delivered and partly because
the media doesn't pay attention there's
not much serious media anymore there's
some but I've seen very little written
about the Obama doctrine and the Obama
doctrine I thought he laid up very well
which is that we will have partners that
we work will cooperate to protect human
rights and to expand the ability of
people to be free and to create their
own democracies if they wish and that we
will respect elections I think Obama
gets very little credit for recognizing
president Morsi and Egypt now I wouldn't
want President Morsi as my president
he's a basically a religious demagogue
and was heading Egypt towards a
non-democratic religious state but he
was he was democratically elected and if
you if you adhere to a democratically
elected philosophy then you have to
respect people's elections I thought
gates made a very good point in his book
when he criticized the President Obama
and Vice President Biden for moving the
Afghan election forward by a few months
because they for that when cars I was
reelected because a variety of reasons
and it didn't have the right candidate
and so forth you can't do that if you're
preaching democracy to other people you
have to the Constitution is absolutely
critical and you have to stick to the
Constitution and have the elections when
the Constitution says not when it's
convenient for whatever reasons but the
but the basic notion here is we want to
foster democracy and we're not going to
do it unilaterally anymore it's not
possible to do it even if we had the
power okay so what would you like your
students to
take away from your class the most
important lesson is big picture Stan
McChrystal did a guest appearance as the
president in a simulation last week and
he was spectacular as always is and his
what his big lesson was you've got to
think of the big problems not the little
problems it's not just about that
somebody is about to attack some ship or
somebody's moving troops here and there
those are the short-term little problems
what does this say about the changing
relationships between nations and
particularly between the United States
and other nations and the most important
lesson of all that I hope to impart in
the 13 weeks that we have is first of
all in order to make decisions you have
to understand culturally where other
nations are coming from because we no
longer live in a unipolar world we can
tell them what they have to do we have
to take their interests and
considerations into serious
consideration and most importantly of
all at this Stan actually said it this
way i want to know that if i make a
decision today what's going to happen
six months from now am I going to be
regretting this decision we absolutely
have to take a long-term view we have to
think about where we're going to be in a
year or two years or three years I don't
think we would have gone into a rack if
we had seriously considered how it was
good how much it was going to benefit
Iran to have American armies take out
Saddam Hussein and if we had known how
much it was going to benefit on I don't
think we would have but I don't think
anybody looked at that because they were
all looking at short-term stuff they
were all ideologically motivated that is
the worst basis of foreign policy that
there could be looking down the road
where do you think things will net out
and Iraq and the Ukraine and I think
Iraq and Syria are finished as countries
this is where this is the remodeling of
the Middle East by forces in the Arab
world as opposed to the British and the
French who remodeled the Middle East
after World War one according to how
they wanted to draw the maps and so
that's going to happen and is it has
already essentially happened I think
Ukraine is going to be a long difficult
hall Putin as he has in georgia with the
taking of Abkhazia away from Georgia
will I I think try to continue to
destabilize Ukraine I think it's going
to be I hope these sanctions work and I
think they have a good
working but it'll be a long term
struggle not a short-term struggle we
had such I thought we had such a decent
relationship with Putin and all of a
sudden you know it turned why do you
think that happened I think you're going
to have to have somebody in this program
is an expert on Russia which I'm not and
Mike McFaul over whose book we're gonna
use a little later in the course is an
expert on Russia just seemed so peculiar
to me I don't think it's entirely / cute
peculiar I think first of all Putin's an
autocrat second all he's basically taken
away most of the democratic institutions
which were sprouting in Russia after the
collapse of the Soviet Union secondly I
think you have to culturally understand
sort of the paranoia of Russian Foreign
Policy's going back to Peter the Great
in order to sense thirdly you have to
understand the humiliation that the
Russians felt which is of course
encouraged by Putin for his own
political reasons after the collapse of
the Soviet Union they somehow field
entitled to own latvia estonia and
lithuania they don't have a democratic
tradition so they don't particularly
respect the right of the lithuanian the
Latvians and the Estonians to do what
they want and they think the same of the
Ukrainians and they have a peculiar view
of history which is work by their own
propaganda it just seemed for a while to
be moving in the right direction and
then it took a very wrong turn I think
if Medvedev was still president with any
power it would have taken going in the
right direction Putin is just the wrong
guy the wrong time remember he is a
trained KGB agent yes and I don't think
he's ever escaped that past and
unfortunately we're not now escaping it
either yeah unfortunately old habits die
hard I think okay final question I have
to ask I've read that you are interested
in running in 2016 for the president I
am NOT you're not no I'm supporting
Hillary Clinton uh okay well I had to
ask I think even though Hillary would be
an exception to this I usually you don't
go back a generation I think Obama
turned the page to a new generation I
think if Hillary doesn't run rather than
my running I think it should be somebody
like Kirsten Gillibrand or something
from a new generation but i do think
Hillary is the most qualified person in
America to be the president and I'm
happily supporting her very good thank
you so much for being here with us today
thanks for having me on for more
information about mr. Dean please visit
our website at yale edu slash mcmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you